Vox would never lie to you right you
trust him it's not like they're slimy
mother time for a rebuttal video this
one's here by popular request the Vox
video on gun control has picked up some
steam I'm surprised no one's addressed
it so right off the bat let me tell you
we'll address why this is propaganda and
it's not a word that I use lightly
people can disagree and sometimes they
have different facts or sources
propaganda can only be used as a label
when they knowingly mislead you which is
the case with this Vox video as will
prove its it's long so let's get to the
video the United States has a problem
with gun violence dramatic music in our
hearts perhaps we might never fill this
Vox video or Cider House Rules we talked
about it after mass shootings but it's
much larger and more complicated than
those debates allowed here's what you
need to know about the state of gun
violence in America it's true that the
u.s. sees many more mass shootings than
these other developed countries between
2000 and 2014 there were 133 mass
shootings in public populated places
that's excluding gang violence and
terrorism so before we get to the point
by point debunking which we'll do here's
the important through-line she uses the
term mass shooting well mass shooting
isn't a legally defined term it's not
even specifically defined in her source
that she includes we'll bring it up here
on the screen there isn't universal
agreement as to what a mass shooting is
which is why it's hard to compile that
as sort of like comparing violent crime
rates different places have different
standards so it's important to note that
because they're going to use this
umbrella term mass shooting to plant the
idea in your head and we'll get to this
very specifically but they want to plant
the idea in your head that with a rise
in legally owned firearms you see an
increase in violent gun crime which is
patently false it's entirely untrue so
it's important to note they're using
mass shooting as the umbrella to make
that point now right away the chart she
uses is misleading because it's not even
per capita the United States has more
population than many of these countries
combined when you look at her original
source at PolitiFact adjusted for per
capita rates the chart is nowhere near
as drastic with even Norway's
which alone in Finland having more
fatalities and deadly mass shootings of
course the u.s. is a much larger country
but if you adjust for population size it
still ranks higher of these countries
Finland is next with just two shootings
over 14 years but a much much smaller
population this is what's misleading she
specifically uses number of mass
shootings not victims or deaths because
even though you see this year Norway and
Finland are comparable relatively in
frequency they have a much higher death
toll on average than American mass
shootings and this type of tragedy seems
to be happening more often in the u.s.
they seems to be an increase in mass
shootings because what they don't tell
you is that violent crime has decreased
again an umbrella non-defined
term like mass shooting is much more
easy to manipulate than the legal
standard of crime which has gone down
each of these squares represents a
public mass shooting with four or more
fatalities before 2011 they happened six
months apart on average but since then
only two months go by between them this
is interesting too whereas before she
was cherry-picking data was kind of
vague all of a sudden she's very
specific and narrowing this to three
it's a psychopathic outliers whose name
you will remember like Columbine
Virginia Tech Sandy Hook also
interesting to note with the exception I
think of Luby's I'm not entirely sure
occurred in gun-free zones
luby's of course only being a decent
food free zone very my tenure as
president
to offer my condolences to families of
these circumstances that was October 1st
2015 and just about two months later San
Bernardino okay hold on a second I
thought all these stats were excluding
gang violence and terrorism that was
what they said at the outset this is
important later on now we're talking
Islamic Isis sympathizers who yelled
Allahu Akbar and opened fire and were
tossing it into the same statistic as
Tommy finding daddy's revolver in the
secret drawer it's okay I'll forgive her
even Barack Obama himself still has San
Bernardino not listed as terrorism but
gun violence wouldn't want to offend
those Muslims let's go back to taking
away your second Amendment rights public
mass shootings get all the attention
because they're often so indiscriminate
but the truth is mass shootings are
unlike most gun deaths in America here's
how it breaks down according to the most
recent data 92 people are killed with
guns every day on average about 30 of
those or homicides of which maybe one
and a half at most can be considered
part of mass shootings real quick
because we'll come back to this 80% of
those gun-related homicides the united
states are drug-related let's go most of
those killed 58 people a day are
suicides the rest are accidental
shootings police actions and
undetermined incidents those suicides
they show up in international
comparisons too these are the 10
countries ranked highest on human
development by the UN she wants to
ignore that because we want to get to
American suicide suicide is a terrible
thing but to use it as a political tool
to remove law abiding citizens basic
human right to self-preservation is
pretty terrible too the reality is that
per capita the United States does not
have an abnormally high suicide rate
here are the countries that do surprise
many of these places are unfree
countries with highly regulated gun
control these are the 10 countries
ranked highest on human development by
the UN the US has the highest suicide
rate of
them and this darker bar shows how many
of those are with guns so now the chart
she cites is specifically countries
ranked highest on human development from
the UN not country to the highest
suicide rates not even in developed
countries which you could say would be
fair you know as opposed to comparing
Zimbabwe in the United States she picks
a very specific vertical for what to
include
sorry South Korea Japan and Poland
apparently you're not developed
countries that Samsung Galaxy is a
figment of your imagination but to go
and think that some type of gun control
regulations that are being talked about
are going to stop somebody from
committing suicide when there's so many
other ways for people commit suicide but
the methods that people use are
important because suicide attempts often
stem from temporary crises the vast
majority of people who survive suicide
attempts don't end up dying from suicide
but guns make it nearly impossible to
get that second chance the victims of
gun suicides are overwhelmingly men and
mostly white now we get into the
personal stories to hit you right in the
fields I do understand that it might be
hard to compare suicide rates across
different countries because of cultural
differences so an example that you do
have would be looking at Australia
before and after the gun ban and the
suicide death rate remains virtually
unchanged though it is interesting to
see Vox say that suicide is correctly
mainly a white male problem check your
priveledge and he's dead to sum this up
the United States does not have a high
suicide rate banning guns has not proven
to be effective in diminishing suicide
and if I'm going to get my own personal
opinion suicide is terrible but it
doesn't infringe on somebody else's
rights so that's a decision you have to
make we have to move on because now
there's a switch and the rate of gun
suicides has been increasing in the US
at the same time the rate of gun
homicides have been decreasing
especially since the 90s when crime
rates in general were higher but if you
compare the u.s. to other developed
countries it doesn't look like good news
these are homicides adjusted for
population size the US would probably
have a higher homicide rate even without
guns but you can see how gun violence
pushes that rate far beyond the other
countries here the victims of these
shootings they're not the ones you often
see on the national news they're
disproportionately young black men just
like that we've switched from suicides
to homicide without skipping a beat to
make some kind of a racial point again
80 percent of homicides the United
States are drug-related and the United
States is nowhere near the top of any
chart for murder rate or even firearm
deaths notice how now unlike before
she's using a stat that includes gang
crime that eighty percent drug-related
homicide might play a factor here you
guys can either go on with your lives we
gotta go up to empty roads because my
children lives were taken away by people
who should not have had gone anyway oh
she's yelling at me like I shouldn't
have a gun again anecdotal information
to personally manipulate the viewer now
it's sad that this lady lost her son but
her son was shot by gang members
statistically gang members aren't buying
their heat at Walmart as a matter of
fact one of the shooters involved in
this incident already was a criminal not
legally capable of purchasing a gun
regardless of whether the gun was legal
in the first place
side note Chicago has some of the
strictest gun laws in the country also
the highest homicide rate unpossible
explanation is that the u.s. simply has
more crime than those other countries
but if you set aside homicides for a
moment and look at rates of burglary or
assault you don't see that same spike
that you see with homicide
cause interesting fact about burglary in
the UK with strict gun control laws mind
you 59 percent of burglaries are what
they call hot burglaries which means the
person is home when the house is big
'old at least they're gonna say you're
being burgled it's not as intimidating
as opposed to the United States where
only 13% of burglaries occur when the
resident is home for reference hot
burglaries have a much higher potential
for violent conflict hmm I wonder what
could be deterring said a hot burglary
stateside
this is why it's important to know when
you're being manipulated when someone's
switching between stats that include
gang violence and terrorism until they
don't because yes the United States
certainly has more gang on gang crime
Europe has a startling trend of more
predator against defenseless victim
crime a big factor for that will address
later on in this video that she never
mentions it's not that America has much
more crime
it's that crime in the u.s. is much more
lethal altogether the number of gun
deaths in the u.s. from 2000 to 2013
exceeds the number of Americans killed
by AIDS by illegal drug overdoses the
Iraq and Afghanistan wars and terrorism
combined it should be clear by now that
this level of gun violence is a uniquely
American problem among the developed
world what did she throw aids in there
age is not a serious problem for most
Americans unless involved in shall we
say very specific activities why would
you include drugs on that list but not
the fact that 80% of gun homicides are
drug-related also how are war casualties
not gun related is this only mortar fire
is it waterboarding outliers what I'm
also imagining this would be skewed
considering that San Bernardino would be
included down here and not up here with
terrorism it should be clear by now that
this level of gun violence is a uniquely
American problem among the developed
world it is important here because she
finishes on the words gun violence but
this big scary black bar is not
indicative of gun violence it's total
firearm related deaths that's important
because when comparing actual gun
homicide rates worldwide the United
States only ranks 28 this is a pivotal
sleight of hand here because this
includes total firearm deaths right
before she pivots this level of gun
violence is a uniquely American problem
among the developed world and here's one
reason why
there are a ton of guns in the US this
chart shows the estimated number of guns
by country it's adjusted for population
size and it's still not even close
I see now this chart is comparing
countries but this chart is not about
homicide it's not about firearm deaths
it's only about gun ownership all this
is designed to lead you into believing
that gun ownership legal gun ownership
results in increased violent gun crime
important to note if gun ownership as
seen in this chart is so much higher but
the United States still ranks 28th in
gun related deaths
why is that the case it also ironically
unravels her own point if gun ownership
is so drastically higher in the United
States but we're only 28 ranked an
overall gun homicide rate that means
proportionally legal gun owners in the
United States are committing fewer
crimes if you take a look back at the 10
countries with the highest levels of
human development you can see that it's
relatively really easy to get a gun in
the US all of the other countries
require a license to purchase most guns
and those purchases are recorded into an
official registry to get that license
people have to state a reason for why
they want a gun and in most of these
countries they have to pass a safety
test and are required by law to store
their guns safely first off it's funny
how they put right to bear arms singling
out the United States as a negative here
in this chart which is tipping their
hand because that's ultimately their end
goal but they'll tell you you're crazy
you're paranoid if you think that
leftists just want to take your guns
away brief history lesson the United
States has a Second Amendment because of
a very different history than these
other countries unlike Canada for
example who bent over for the king the
United States decided to fight for
freedom and we wanted to hang on to that
right to ensure that we were never taken
over by a tyrant like oh I don't know
say Hitler something else to note along
with the 80% drug-related gun homicide
is most gun crime occurs in heavily
populated areas urban areas big cities
and the United States has more big
cities than many countries on this list
combined which is why many crime bureaus
readily admit that comparing violent
crimes across different countries is
nearly impossible to do in part because
of its lacks laws there are well over
300 million guns in the US
and Counting this chart doesn't reflect
private sales but it shows the number of
background checks which all federally
licensed dealers have to run it suggests
that the demand for guns has been
increasing steeply since Barack Obama
took office this part is absolutely true
despite how hard it is to trust someone
who can't properly spell Obama I know
with Barack Obama's demagoguery people
were concerned and many did exercise
their second Amendment right for the
very first time
hence the legal background checks oh no
wait that that's a bad thing now side
note violent crime has still been
decreasing matter of fact firearm
related homicides have gone down a
whopping 39% from 1993 to 2011 which is
important to note because this steep
scary graph is designed to plant the
idea in your head that more legal gun
owners equals more gun crime not true
matter of fact in a study in 1994 they
found that only 21 percent of gun crimes
involved a firearm purchase to a store
or traditional outlet meaning legally
the most recent study would suggest that
it's closer to between 3 and 11 percent
there's a variance because these issues
are kind of hard to study felons aren't
known for their truthful integrity again
this unravels her argument because
regardless of background checks the
amount of gun crime committed by legal
firearm owners is either the same or
very likely lower than before rendering
this graph irrelevant next point so
we've looked at gun deaths and at gun
ownership
this chart puts them together it shows
that among highly developed countries
the more guns in a country the more gun
deaths you can see that countries like
Switzerland which have relatively more
guns than a country like the Netherlands
also have a higher gun death rate and
here's the u.s. see the sleight-of-hand
we were just talking about homicide and
gun purchases now we're back to gun
deaths not homicide or violent crime
because those would include suicides or
violent intruders or criminals being
killed by law-abiding gun owning
homeowners likewise US states with more
guns have more gun homicides there are
outliers like Idaho which has higher
rates of gun ownership but low rates of
gun murders but overall there's a
correlation between gun ownership and
homicide rates
and that relationship has held up in
studies that control for things like
poverty unemployment and crime actually
know those outliers can be explained
because there's a strong correlation
between gun deaths and big populated
cities and gang violence that's why the
sleight of hand is important sometimes
she includes it sometimes she doesn't
and if this particular study doesn't
include big cities but poverty it
renders it irrelevant because poverty is
still the biggest indicator for violent
crime far more so than mere gun
ownership the correlation between gun
ownership and gun deaths is even
stronger for suicides it makes sense no
it doesn't then if it does look behind
you there's what made sense oppression
with a gun is more dangerous than
depression without one okay this again
brings us back to the fact that the
United States does not have an
abnormally high suicide rate so now she
wants to blame the conjoining of guns
and depression but earlier she admitted
that middle-aged white men make up an
abnormally high percentage of the
suicide rate even though women are more
likely to suffer from depression so
again the mind trickery we've gone from
blaming the gun to now blaming
depression and the gun which counteracts
your previous statement on suicides to
begin with likewise fights domestic
disputes road rage drunkenness all much
more dangerous with a gun than without
that said you might need different
policies to keep guns away from
potential mass shooters then you would
to keep them out of inner-city gangs or
out of the hands of someone who might
hurt themselves America doesn't have a
gun problem it has several of them okay
so here's the big takeaway this video
has equally represented mass shootings
suicide and gang violence as though they
proportionally contribute to the gun
related problem despite the fact that
eighty percent of gun homicides in the
United States are drug-related despite
the fact that the biggest indicators of
gun crime are big populated areas and
poverty despite the fact that the United
States is not even in the top 25 in
firearm related deaths despite the fact
that the United States does not have an
abnormally high suicide rate despite the
fact that was increased legal gun
ownership gun crime has actually
steadily declined and despite the fact
that Vox had a beautiful canvas to work
with at the outset by using the
relative mass shooting which was
completely undefined and even included
acts of terrorism like San Bernardino
it's one thing to get your information
wrong it's another to deliberately
mislead people because the facts don't
stack up with your narrative so when you
look at the actual statistics and data
that we've presented here there are some
solutions where we could find common
ground things like project exile which
we've covered at the website where you
have harsh penalties for felons
illegally carrying firearms things that
deter criminals from getting firearms or
carrying firearms because that is where
the problem truly lies but they'll never
present this information to you at Vox
let's assume for a second that you
believe everything Vox presented here to
be true that the United States had a
staggeringly high suicide rate
abnormally high homicide rate that there
was a correlation between legal gun
owners and gun violence and firearm
related deaths
how could you fix that problem that's
important they've already shown you it
wouldn't be some kind of an arbitrary
assault weapons ban which really these
weapons don't comprise of most of this
gun violence anyway it wouldn't be some
kind of a limitation on magazine
capacities it would have to be of course
in all-out gun ban declaring that you
legally do not have the right to
self-preservation which is in fact what
several Supreme Court justices argued
before the High Court that none of you
have the right to own firearms period
for any reason unless your jurisdiction
deems it so but don't worry you're just
crazy thinking that people like Vox want
to take your guns away video you must be
new to the Internet because there's a
lot of better content out there but if
you're still here you might want to
click this big box where you can see my
rebuttal to the young turks and their
anti firearm propaganda or click my face
here to go to the website or you can
find all of our references and sources
linked for this video you don't have to
take my word for it there's also a video
below me I don't know what it is there
was a levar burton reference Reading
Rainbow